hey what's up guys my name is Samuel
EADS I'm a property investor and on this
YouTube channel my mission my goal is to
help make as many people become
financially free and successful as
possible in property now often what
happens is I'll make a video and then
I'll get lots of niggly questions
detailed questions around tax due
diligence and I like to every Sunday
answer those questions from my from my
followers so on this week's video I'm
going to be answering some of those
questions however if you're watching
this right now what I want you to do is
I want you to ask me by commenting below
ask me your property problems questions
the little niggles the things that you
always think I wish I knew he answer
this anything around property money
finance mortgages tax comment below and
I will do my best to answer based on my
experience as a property investor so
let's have a look at some of the
questions we've had from last week and
as you're listening start commenting
typing below and I'll be doing another
video next week answering your questions
as well so what we got James Ramsey says
how do you estimate HMO utility costs
gas electric water council tax and Wi-Fi
etc how much does this affect your
return on investment
so of course affect your return on
investment so HMO property if anyone
doesn't know as a house on multiple
occupancy so it's when you buy a house
rather than just renting it out to a
family you rent it out room by room
which is gonna which massively pushes up
your rent
however when you do that you usually
what I recommend doing is you pay for
the utility bills you pay for the
council tax that way it makes it easy
for the tenant to move in makes it easy
for the tent it's convenient and in 2020
convenient sales so how much should you
budget for those utility costs so it
does vary a little bit depending on the
house so if it's a new build or if it's
a really old house it will vary but
typically speaking are usually budget
around about 350 pounds for a four-bed
hmm and then as you go up by the rooms
if it's a five bed I've got up 50 pounds
and then if this is six-bed I'll go up
to 50 pounds so it might be 450 pounds
for a six bed hmm now that is a rule of
thumb that's not an absolute definite I
use a company called utility warehouse
for my utility bills I'm not affiliated
with them I was a distributor like ten
years ago but now I do is I have my find
distributors for utility warehouse I
give them all my properties I give them
like my houses and then the distributors
kind of like to feel like they owe me a
favor so they might make five pounds a
month commission from my property but
then because they kind of feel like
they're me little bit of a favor they'll
then pass me property deals which might
make me a hundred thousand pounds so
it's kind of a win-win for me but
they're a good company another thing
I'll say on HMOs generally speaking is
sometimes you can look at the property
and you can be like oh my gosh I went
out six bedrooms 400-pounder room I'm
gonna make like two and a half thousand
pound a month rent but the thing is half
of that rent is going to go towards
expenses so you can have interest
payments on your mortgage gas electric
management half generally speaking rule
of thumb half of the rent is going to go
on expenses and then half is going to be
left as pre-tax profit so that's again a
rule of thumb I hope that helped James
any more questions on HMOs just drop a
comment below in this video I'm Baron
Tass how do you lower the amount of
taxes you pay in property great question
how do you lower taxes okay first thing
I'll say is this
don't let the tail wag the dog so you're
right now your number one priorities to
make money and then when you make money
it's then a case of okay now how do i
how do I save money how do I pay as
little tax as possible so how do you do
that I mean the most obvious ways to
just reduce your reduce your profits so
everything that you buy you need to you
need to be really good at knowing can
you put it on the business or can you
not this t-shirt okay that I'm wearing
right now
this is not an expensive t-shirt
sometimes people say to me Samuel you
know why do you wear that top from next
or whatever that's 15 pounds laughs I
thought you were supposed to be with a
property multi-millionaire and and my
answer is well firstly while I wouldn't
know where the top
you know what's the issue but secondly
because this top is not tax deductible
I'm not gonna spend a lot of money on
stuff there's not tax deductible so I'm
always thinking you know what can i what
what can I claim as an expense that's
why now when I apply properties i buy
them through a limited company because
that means that my mortgage payments the
interest payments are tax deductible
because I'm buying it through a company
if you buy it as an individual it's not
so I'm always thinking how can I stand
Gigi tax having used a of stamp duty tax
you you can you can instead of buy if
there's a property owned in a company
instead of buying the property you can
buy the company that owns the property
and then you stamp duty tax goes down
almost to zero when you go on a course
so for people that go on my training
programs whether even if it's a free
course even if they come on the crash
course which is a free two day program
the hotel bill so when they're sleeping
over the hotel bill in them then the
evening dinner
as long as it's it you can you can
demonstrate that I was staying at this
hotel because I was learning about
property that is tax deductible which
means that then when you make your big
fat profit you can say I've got my big
fat profit but I had this expense and
this expense and this expense so knowing
what you can class as an expense and
what is not an expense is a really
important skill to reduce your tax so
that's just a few things but the most
important things to make money I don't
think you pay any tax at all when you
when you start off as a property
entrepreneur you don't pay any tax on
the first eleven thousand pounds I think
always check out all this stuff with an
accountant because I'm not qualified to
get tax advice I can only speak from my
experience first eleven thousand pounds
you don't pay any tax and then there's a
sliding scale so as you get wealthier
and wealthier you pay more more tax
which is why you're then going to look
for more expenses so that was nothing
grant cardone said to me he was like
dude you need you need more expenses
you're almost making too much profit and
when you have too much profit that's not
actually a good thing because then
you're gonna have to pay lots of tax so
how can you how can you invest that
money that profit into stuff that's
gonna grow your business so there's just
a few thoughts anyway I mean I could
literally run a whole stem
on tax because it's something that I'm
very interested in it's something that
when you make a lot of money you want to
save it but I wouldn't get super hung up
about it unless you're making lots of
money that should always be the priority
hope that helps thank you for your
question behind okay
Gonzales said we're looking for rent to
sa deals do I look for furnished
apartments or unfurnished and furnish
them myself either whatever makes the
best return on investment you always
just need to factor in costs so if
you've got an apartment and it's not
furnished just make sure that when
you're working out the return on
investment you include either leasing
the furniture so you knock off the
monthly expense or you include in the
return on investment having to shell out
money on furniture whatever gives you
the best return on investment is the
best deal sometimes I'll have to furnish
properties or lease furniture but I've
got such a good deal on it that we turn
investments still really good other
times it just it just really does depend
either is define and if you are gonna
get but if you're gonna pay for
furniture then you're gonna spend a lot
of money on any kind of rent to renting
or a lease option agreement just make
sure that you have got the agreement
drawn up properly with the landlord
because the last thing you want to do is
start shelling out on to buying
expensive furniture in a property and
then the landlord goes actually you know
what I'll just I'll just read this out
myself and then you put all this money
so just make sure that you've got the
correct paperwork to protect you if you
do this closet deals
Stevi ball how many properties did you
have at the end of the first year at the
end of the first year I don't know what
that means
does that mean the first year of me
being born or does that mean I don't
know what that means
if you mean when I started out in
property so when I started out in
property it was after twelve months of
me starting I had one one day I had one
house so I you know what it took me four
years to become financially free and
knowing what I know now is I started all
over again which I have done many times
is my financial freedom challenges what
I achieved in four years I can very
easily achieve in four months now maybe
even four weeks because your first deal
is always your hardest once you've done
your first deal then
you just gonna duplicate and then
duplicate and it gets easier and easier
just like anything like though to drive
so I hope that was what you wanted to
know Stevie Stevie ball one property
after my first year vesting in property
okay dr cam hey Sam you another great
video thank you I've just secured to
rent to serviced a combination
properties all thanks to your videos
whoa good Java brilliant I've also
booked on to the next crash course next
week dude amazing oh I'll be there next
week as well so I'll see you there
just wondering if you could advise
before I start question with such a high
turnover with rent - serviced
accommodation what's the best way to
cover myself and the landlord for
potential damage done to the property by
the temporary guest okay to protect
yourself against guests damaging the
property deposits deposits deposits
deposits just make sure you have any
posit from the guest but but dude we can
we can we can cover that wall of the
crash course you're going to be there
next week anyway Congrats on your two
deals
that's insane I'm glad you're gonna be
at the crash course next week so you do
it right because there are people taking
massive action is fantastic but you also
need to take massive action with also
knowledge and I do see people doing rent
to rent and they do it wrong and they
get burned so really glad you're going
to be there next week boom I'll see you
there
okay II think Harold gallium says loving
your free information thank you for
taking the time dude you're welcome it's
my pleasure do you think how you present
yourself is a key factor when securing
your property or management companies
etc on a face-to-face basis presenting
yourself yet
Ethan presenting yourself is really
important at the end of the day money
does not come from property money comes
from people because if you think about
it you buy a house that house isn't
going to give you any money what's going
to give you the money is the tenet that
moves into the house the tenants going
to give you money because of the
property when the house goes up in value
and you want to sell it maybe the house
doesn't sell itself
someone has to buy the house and someone
has to buy the house based on what they
think it's worth so if money comes from
people are not property then being able
to communicate and articulate yourself
and present yourself properly
professionally in a way that's likable
trustworthy is really really important
so and I see some people this is this is
this is where they down so they study
all the theory and they might know loads
about property you could know as much
about me in property but then if you
haven't got the ability to speak to
people and I'm not talking about being a
charismatic presenter okay maybe you
won't be speak like I speak not saying
I'm a charismatic presenter but maybe
you won't speak like I speak but just
being able to be you in your way but
don't have to carry yourself properly
and use the right language when you're
speaking to people because the language
is really important the right phrases
all that kind of stuff it's really
really important so you know work on
that as well work on your personal
development work on growing yourself and
your people skills and your negotiation
skills as well as your property skills
hundred percent twenty percent and we do
some of that other crash course as well
the crash courses both the property
investors craft skills by the way which
is a two-day course I created it's now
served thousands and thousands of people
all across the world and we work on the
property side knowing how to work out
the figures and find a deal but also how
to speak to the agent how to speak to
negotiate with the seller how to find
the tenant how to put the Power Team
together so the two of really really
born okay last question I hope you guys
enjoy this if you enjoying this video
please don't forget to smash that like
button and if you're watching this and
you're not subscribe to the channel then
please subscribe right now all right one
more
kaydee man jr. hey Sammy great videos
love them thank you can you please
confirm your understanding as multiple
dwelling relief when you are purchasing
a property that's been converted to
separate flats with their own interests
kitchen bathrooms etc we're buying a
property with five flats does this mean
we decide the cost we divide I think I
supposed to say the cost of stamp duty
into five due to the number of flats and
if that means they are below a specific
threshold then we pay less than due to
any sport bars are appreciated
great question listen is quite a big
subject stats down duty and how you work
it out
but yes 100% I've got experience of this
when I've bought properties that have
been even when I bought the castle in
fact when I bought the castle always
quoted by my solicitor I think it was
eighty-six thousand pounds in stamp duty
and I was like oh goodness and I said
but the castle is actually already got
planning permissions to be multiple
apartments multiple houses while I pay
some extensions you know looked into it
never I know you've got to pay it and I
just thinking this doesn't seem right
and I was researching it online then I
was in fact you can even go to let me
look at the website if you go to Google
you K guidance slash Stamp Duty Land Tax
Relief okay
bit of an apple just google it if you if
you google you can get a lot of
information about Staunton account works
it might be confusing so you want to
find a solicitor that can explain it in
plain English knows the craic because I
taste in it when you over the pace down
duty the HMRC aren't going to come after
you and say you know what you actually
overpaid you paid eighty six thousand
pound when you could have paid eight
thousand pounds let me give you the
seventy eight thousand pound back that's
not how it works you need to you need to
put the put to put the put the claim in
it yourself with your sister when you
buy the house so with the castle it came
down to 8,000 pounds line change
solicitor and and I've got it down to
eight thousand pounds which is just
insane because I've got multiple
dwellings really so I might do a whole
video about that and how it works you
can google it but right now I think
we're going to wrap up because I've been
going on quite a while but listen if
you've got more questions
and that's thumb do you think I'm gonna
do a whole new separate video about that
on its own right because I think it's a
big subject but if you've got more
questions and you want to me to answer
you comment them below if you want to
come to the property investors crash
course you can get yourself booked on
for free it's an incredible two-day
program and you can get books um right
here if you want to see me becoming
financially free all again from scratch
you can do that right here and please
don't forget to subscribe down over here
thanks so much guys I'll see you next
time